But from now on, I'll
show you a part of the Spirit's miracles. You're
having problems with your relationships.
[Music] I'm proud of you.
How do you know?
Yukito-san, I never thought you'd notice my feelings, and the
Spirit would use the power of God to touch your heart.
This is the
so-called
Barnum effect, a
convenient psychological effect that happens when fraudulent fortune tellers say something vague that applies to everyone.
Make me believe in the power of you. I'm amazing. I don't
rest as much as I read your heart. What you're
worried about is the
increase in the number of monsters. Are your boobs getting too big?
By the way, Yuki and I liked smaller ones.
Smaller ones.  I like it. I like it when it's small.
[Music]
Somebody please
lend me your ax.
No, I liked OK. The
spirits can look into people's hearts, so they
can understand Yukito's true feelings.
That's a different story.
My god is so stupid that I do
n't know how to collect pearls. Why can't the
people of this village understand how good I am?